étaient extrêmement basses pour la Corée.
Leur idée était que, sans aide internationale, la Corée aurait du mal
à assurer autre chose que les premières nécessités de son peuple.
La situation en Corée est difficile,
mes parents avaient vu ce qu'était la vie aux États-Unis.
Ils s'y sont mariés. Mon frère y est né.
Ils pensaient que pour nous donner l'opportunité
d'atteindre les aspirations qu'ils avaient pour nous,
il nous fallait partir et revenir aux États-Unis.
Nous sommes revenus.
Nous sommes allés à Dallas.
Mon père a repassé son diplôme de dentiste.
Puis nous avons emménagé en Iowa.
Nous avons grandi en Iowa.
Et en Iowa, nous avons suivi tout le cursus scolaire.
J'ai été au lycée, j'ai été à l'université.
Et puis un jour, quelque chose que je n'oublierai jamais,
mon père est venu me chercher après ma deuxième année à l'université,
il me ramenait à la maison
et il a dit : « Quelles sont tes aspirations ?
Que veux-tu étudier ? Que veux-tu faire ? »
Et j'ai dit : « Papa » --
ma mère était une philosophe et nous avait nourris d'idées
sur la protestation et la justice sociale
et j'ai dit : « Papa, je vais étudier les sciences politiques et la philosophie
et je vais faire partie d'un mouvement politique. »
Mon père, le dentiste coréen,
s'est doucement rangé sur le bord de la route.
(Rires)
Il m'a regardé et a dit :
« Jim, tu finis ta résidence en médecine et tu peux étudier ce que tu veux. »
(Rires)
J'ai raconté cette histoire à un public majoritairement asiatique.
Personne ne rigole. Ils ne font que hocher la tête.
Bien sûr.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Tragiquement, mon père est mort jeune,
il y a 30 ans, à l'âge de 57 ans.
Il s'avère que c'est mon âge actuel
et quand il est mort au milieu de mes études de médecine...
J'avais contourné cela en étudiant la médecine et l'anthropologie.
J'étudiais les deux à l'université.
Mais à cette période-là, j'ai rencontré deux personnes,
Ophelia Dahl et Paul Farmer.
Paul et moi étions dans le même programme.
Nous étudiions la médecine
et en même temps obtenions notre doctorat en anthropologie.
Nous avons commencé à poser des questions fondamentales.
Pour les gens ayant le privilège d'étudier la médecine et l'anthropologie --
mes parents étaient des réfugiés.
Paul a littéralement grandi dans un bus dans un marais en Floride.
Il aimait s'appeler « blanc pauvre ».
Nous avions cette opportunité
et nous avons dit :
« Que devons-nous faire ? »
Étant donnée notre éducation ridiculement élaborée,
quelle est la nature de notre responsabilité envers le monde ?
Nous avons décidé que nous devions lancer une organisation.
Elle s'appelle Partners in Health.
Et il y a eu un film à ce sujet.
(Applaudissements)
Il y a un film brillant
sur ce sujet : « Bending the Arc ».
Il a été lancé à Sundance en janvier dernier.
Jeff Skoll est ici.
Jeff Skoll est l'un de ceux qui ont réalisé cela.
Nous avons commencé à réfléchir à ce qu'il nous faudrait
pour que nos aspirations atteignent le niveau
des communautés les plus pauvres du monde.
C'est ma toute première visite à Haïti en 1988
et en 1988, nous avons élaboré une définition de mission
qui était de créer une option préférentielle pour les pauvres
en termes de santé.
Cela nous a pris beaucoup de temps et nous étions étudiants en anthropologie.
D'un côté nous lisions Marx, de l'autre Habermas, Fernand Braudel.
Nous lisions tout
et nous étions arrivés à une conclusion sur la manière de structurer notre action.
Nous l'avons appelé « O pour les P »,
une option préférentielle pour les pauvres.
La chose la plus importante à ce sujet
est ce que ce n'est pas.
Ce n'est pas une option préférentielle pour votre propre sens de l'héroïsme,
ni une option préférentielle
pour votre idée sur la manière de sortir les pauvres de la pauvreté,
ni une option préférentielle pour votre propre organisation.
Et le plus dur,
ce n'est pas une option préférentielle pour vos pauvres.
C'est une option préférentielle pour les pauvres.
Que faire ?
Haïti, nous avons commencé à bâtir --
Tout le monde nous a dit que ce qui était rentable
était la vaccination et un programme alimentaire.
Mais les Haïtiens voulaient un hôpital.
Ils voulaient des écoles.
Ils voulaient offrir à leurs enfants les opportunités
dont ils avaient entendu parler via d'autres, des parents par exemple,
qui étaient partis aux États-Unis.
Ils voulaient le même genre d'opportunités que celles que voulaient mes parents.
Je les reconnaissais.
C'est ce que nous avons fait : bâtir des hôpitaux,
assurer l'éducation.
Nous avons fait tout notre possible pour leur offrir des opportunités.
Mon expérience est devenue très intense
à Partners in Health dans cette communauté, Carabayllo,
dans les bidonvilles du nord de Lima, au Pérou.
Dans cette communauté,
nous avons commencé par aller parler aux gens chez eux
et avons découvert une épidémie de tuberculose résistante aux médicaments.
Voici Melquiades.
Melquiades était un patient à l'époque, il avait environ 18 ans
et il avait une forme très difficile de tuberculose résistante aux médicaments.
Tous les gourous de la santé mondiale
ont dit que ce n'était pas rentable
de soigner une tuberculose résistante aux médicaments.
C'est trop compliqué. C'est trop cher.
Vous n'y arriverez pas. C'est impossible.
En plus de cela, ils s'énervaient contre nous
car l'implication était
que si c'était possible, nous l'aurions fait.
Pour qui vous prenez-vous ?
Nous nous battions contre l'Organisation Mondiale de la Santé
et l'organisation contre laquelle nous nous battions le plus
était la Banque mondiale.
Nous avons fait tout notre possible
pour convaincre Melquiades de prendre ses médicaments
car c'est très difficile,
et pas une fois durant le traitement la famille de Melquiades a dit :
« Hey, vous savez, Melquiades n'est pas rentable.
Pourquoi ne pas aller soigner quelqu'un d'autre ? »
(Rires)
Je n'avais pas revu Melquiades en 10 ans
et quand nous avons tenu nos réunions annuelles à Lima, au Pérou,
il y a deux ans,
les cinéastes l'ont trouvé
et nous voilà réunis.
(Applaudissements)
Il est devenu une star des médias car il va aux avant-premières
et sait comment se comporter avec le public.
(Rires)
Mais dès que nous avons gagné --
Nous avons remporté le débat.
Il fallait soigner la tuberculose résistante aux médicaments --
nous avons entendu la même chose au début des années 2000 pour le VIH.
Toutes les personnes éminentes en santé mondiale ont dit
qu'il était impossible de soigner le VIH dans les pays pauvres.
Trop cher, trop compliqué, c'est impossible.
Comparé au traitement de la TB résistante,
c'est plus facile.
Nous voyions des patients ainsi.
Joseph Jeune.
Joseph Jeune n'a jamais évoqué le fait de ne pas être rentable.
Quelques mois de médicaments et voici ce à quoi il ressemblait.
(Applaudissements)
Nous appelons cela l'effet Lazare du traitement du VIH.
Joseline est venue nous voir ainsi.
Voici ce à quoi elle ressemblait quelques mois plus tard.
(Applaudissements)
Nous pensions que notre dispute, notre combat
était contre les organisations qui disaient que ce n'était pas rentable.
Nous disions non,
l'option préférentielle pour les pauvres
nécessitait une rehausse de nos aspirations
pour satisfaire celles des pauvres.
Ils disaient que c'était une pensée sympathique mais pas rentable.
De la même façon dont nous avons dirigé Partners in Health,
nous avons écrit un livre contre la Banque mondiale.
Il dit cela : la Banque mondiale
s'est tant concentrée uniquement sur la croissance économique
et a dit que les gouvernements devaient diminuer leurs budgets
et réduire les dépenses en santé, éducation et aide sociale --
nous pensions que c'était fondamentalement mauvais.
Nous avons débattu avec la Banque mondiale.
Puis une chose folle est arrivée.
Le président Obama m'a nommé pour être président de la Banque mondiale.
(Applaudissements)
Lors du processus de validation avec l'équipe du Président Obama,
ils avaient une copie de « Dying For Growth » et l'avaient lu.
J'ai dit : « C'est fini, hein ?
Vous allez me laisser tomber ? »
Il a dit : « Non, non, c'est bon. »
J'ai été nommé
et en juillet 2012, j'ai passé la porte du groupe de la Banque mondiale
et cette déclaration sur le mur : « Notre rêve est un monde sans pauvreté ».
Quelques mois après cela, nous l'avons transformée en but :
mettre un terme à la pauvreté extrême d'ici à 2030,
stimuler la prospérité partagée.
C'est ce qu'on fait à la Banque mondiale.
J'ai l'impression d'avoir apporté l'option préférentielle pour les pauvres
à la Banque mondiale.
(Applaudissements)
Mais nous sommes à TED
et je veux partager quelques inquiétudes
puis faire une proposition.
La quatrième révolution industrielle,
que vous connaissez bien mieux que moi,
mais voilà ce qui m'inquiète.
Nous entendons tous parler de perte d'emplois.
Nos données suggèrent que deux tiers des emplois
existant dans les pays en développement
seront perdus face à l'automatisation.
Il faudra compenser ces emplois.
Une façon d'y arriver
est de faire des travailleurs de santé une vraie force de travail.
C'est ce que nous voulons faire.
(Applaudissements)
Nous pensons que c'est une solution,
qu'avec l'amélioration de la santé et des gens ayant un travail officiel,
nous pourrons les former
aux compétences relationnelles nécessaires
pour devenir des travailleurs qui auront un fort impact
et ce pourrait être le domaine avec le plus de croissance.
Mais voici l'autre chose qui me dérange :
actuellement, il me semble clair que les emplois du futur
seront plus exigeants numériquement
et il y a une crise de croissance.
Voici des photos de Charles Nelson qu'il a partagées avec nous
de la Harvard Medical School.
Ces photos montrent d'un côté, à gauche,
un enfant de trois mois ayant une croissance retardée :
pas de nutrition adéquate, pas de stimulation adéquate.
De l'autre côté, évidemment, il y a un enfant normal
et l'enfant normal a toutes ces connexions neuronales.
Les connexions neuronales sont importantes
car c'est la définition du capital humain.
Nous savons que nous pouvons réduire ces taux.
Nous pouvons rapidement réduire ces taux de croissance retardée
mais si nous ne le faisons pas en Inde par exemple,
où il y a 38% de croissances retardées,
comment vont-ils rivaliser dans l'économie du futur
si 40% de leurs futurs travailleurs ne peuvent pas réussir éducativement,
et nous nous inquiétons bien sûr de la réussite économique,
d'une façon qui permette à tout le pays de croître.
Qu'allons-nous faire ?
L'économie mondiale représente 78 billions de dollars.
8,55 billions sont des obligations à taux d'intérêts négatifs.
Cela signifie que vous donnez votre argent à la banque centrale allemande,
puis vous les payez pour garder votre argent.
C'est un taux d'intérêts négatif.
Il y a 24,4 billions de dollars d'obligations à faibles revenus.
Et 8 billions se trouvent dans les mains des gens riches,
sous leurs très gros matelas.
Nous essayons d'utiliser nos propres outils --
pour la jouer intello une seconde,
de gestion du risque de première tranche de perte,
de diminution des risques, de financements mixtes,
d'une assurance risque politique,
de rehaussement de crédit --
toutes ces choses que j'ai apprises à la Banque mondiale
que les gens riches utilisent au quotidien pour devenir plus riches
mais que nous n'avons pas utilisés assez agressivement au nom des pauvres
pour attirer ce capital.
(Applaudissements)
Est-ce que cela fonctionne ?
Pouvez-vous vraiment faire intervenir des acteurs du privé dans un pays
et faire que ça marche ?
Nous l'avons fait quelques fois.
Nous sommes en Zambie, Scaling Solar.
C'est une solution intégrée de la Banque mondiale
où nous venons et faisons tout le nécessaire
pour attirer des investisseurs privés.
Dans ce cas, la Zambie est passée d'un coût de l'électricité
à 25 centimes par kilowatt-heure
et, en ne faisant que des choses simples, en vendant aux enchères,
en changeant quelques politiques,
nous avons pu réduire le prix.
Offre la plus basse :
25 centimes le kilowatt-heure pour la Zambie ?
L'offre la plus basse était 4,7 centimes par kilowatt-heure. C'est possible.
(Applaudissements)
Mais voici ma proposition.
C'est un groupe appelé Zipline,
une entreprise sympa et ce sont des spécialistes des fusées.
Ils ont trouvé comment utiliser des drones au Rwanda.
Me voici lançant un drone au Rwanda,
il livre du sang n'importe où dans le pays
en moins d'une heure.
Nous sauvons des vies,
ce programme sauve des vies --
(Applaudissements)
Il a rapporté de l'argent à Zipline
et il a permis au Rwanda d'épargner beaucoup d'argent.
Nous avons besoin de cela de la part de vous tous.
Je vous demande de garder un peu de temps dans votre cerveau
pour réfléchir à vos technologies,
vos entreprises, votre design.
Réfléchissez un peu et travaillez avec nous
pour voir si nous pouvons trouver des solutions extraordinaires
où tout le monde gagne.
Je vais vous raconter une dernière histoire.
J'étais en Tanzanie, dans une salle de classe.
Me voici dans une salle de classe d'enfants de 11 ans.
Je leur ai demandé :
« Vous voulez faire quoi une fois grands ? »
Deux ont levé la main et dit :
« Je veux être le président de la Banque mondiale. »
(Rires)
Tout comme vous, mon équipe et leurs professeurs ont rigolé.
Mais je les ai arrêtés.
J'ai dit : « Je veux vous raconter une histoire.
Quand je suis né en Corée du Sud, voilà ce à quoi cela ressemblait.
Voilà d'où je viens.
Quand j'avais trois ans,
en maternelle,
je ne pense pas que George David Woods, le président de la Banque mondiale,
s'il avait fait une visite en Corée et était venu dans ma classe,
qu'il aurait prensé
que le futur président de la Banque mondiale
était assis dans cette classe.
Ne laissez personne vous dire
que vous ne pouvez pas être le président de la Banque mondiale. »
Merci.
(Applaudissements)
Une dernière pensée :
je viens d'un pays qui était le plus pauvre du monde.
Je suis président de la Banque mondiale.
Je ne peux pas et ne veux pas enlever l'échelle après mon passage.
C'est urgent.
Les aspirations croissent.
Partout, les aspirations croissent.
Vous dans cette pièce, travaillez avec nous !
Nous savons que nous pouvons trouver des solutions comme Zipline
et aider les pauvres à entrer dans un monde meilleur,
mais cela n'arrivera que si nous travaillons ensemble.
Votre futur « moi » -- en particulier pour vos enfants --
votre futur moi
dépendra de l'attention et de la compassion que nous mettons
à assurer que le futur nous offre une égalité des chances
à tous les enfants du monde.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)
Merci. Merci. Merci.
Chris Anderson : On peut trouver
une telle intervention surprenante,
venant du président de la Banque mondiale.
C'est plutôt cool.
Je vous encourage à faire une proposition plus spécifique.
Il y a beaucoup d'investisseurs, d'entrepreneurs dans cette pièce.
Quels partenariats ferez-vous ? Que proposez-vous ?
Jim Yong Kim : Je peux jouer un peu à l'intello ?
CA : Absolument. JYK : Voici ce qu'on a fait.
Les assurances n'investissent pas
dans l'infrastructure des pays en développement
car c'est trop risqué.
Elles gardent leur argent pour les gens qui paient.
La Swedish International Development Association
nous a donné un peu d'argent,
nous avons collecté un peu plus de fonds, cent millions,
et nous avons une première perte, si cela tourne mal,
nous encaisserons 10% de la perte
et le reste sera sécurisé.
Cela a créé une tranche de 90%,
c'est un investissement triple B, les assurances ont donc investi.
Nous prenons de l'argent public
et l'utilisons pour diminuer les risques d'obligations spécifiques
pour attirer des gens extérieurs.
Tous ceux qui sont assis sur un milliard en liquide,
venez nous voir.
(Rires)
CA : Vous cherchez particulièrement des propositions d'investissement
qui créent des emplois dans le monde en développement.
JYK : Absolument.
Ce sera, par exemple, des infrastructures qui apportent de l'énergie,
créent des routes, des ponts, des ports.
Ce genre de choses nécessaires à la création d'emplois,
mais nous disons aussi
que la technologie ou l'entreprise sur laquelle vous travaillez
pourrait, à votre avis, ne pas s'appliquer au monde en développement
mais regardez Zipline.
Zipline n'est pas arrivée
juste du fait de la qualité de la technologie.
Ils se sont intéressés aux Rwandais tôt,
ont utilisé l'intelligence artificielle --
le Rwanda a une super bande passante --
mais ces choses volent toutes seules.
Nous vous aiderons à le faire. Nous ferons les présentations.
Nous fournirons un financement. Nous vous aiderons.
CA : Quel capital la Banque mondiale souhaite-t-elle affecter
au soutien de ces efforts ?
JYK : Chris, vous essayez toujours quelque chose comme ça.
CA : Je vous attire des problèmes. JYK : Voici ce que nous allons faire.
Nous investissons chaque année 25 milliards dans les pays pauvres,
les pays les plus pauvres.
En investissant les trois prochaines années,
25 milliards par an,
nous devons penser avec vous
et comment utiliser cet argent plus efficacement.
Je n'ai pas de chiffre précis. Cela dépend de la qualité des idées.
Venez nous voir avec vos idées
et je ne pense pas que le financement sera un problème.
CA : Très bien, vous avez l'info à la source.
Jim, merci beaucoup. JYK : Merci. Merci.
(Applaudissements)